[Music]
it's been a crazy week in america let's
find out what happened
a jury this week found former
minneapolis police officer derek shovin
guilty on all three
charges in the murder trial of george
floyd
and it was as simple as 1 2
3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 11
12 13. police in california responded
to a suspected home intrusion broke down
the front door and
found the family's robot vacuum they
left
peacefully after performing a clean
sweep
no i'm kidding they shot and killed the
robot
[Laughter]
it was recently reported that scammers
are selling coronavirus vaccination
cards
that are fake here's what a real
vaccination card looks like
and here's a fake one um you can tell
today
yeah all right i can tell when it's fake
in an effort to reflect heat away from
surfaces
engineers at purdue university recently
created the whitest
paint ever it's so white how white
is it the paint is so white it drives a
prius
this paint is so white
this paint is so wide it went to harvard
on a golf scholarship
oh oops okay there we go
this paint is so white
this paint is so white when a recipe
calls for salt it throws out the recipe
oh this spring is so white
it's so white that this weekend it's
going camping
this paint is so white this paint is so
white that i said
hey can you believe minneapolis and it
said did something happen in minneapolis
guys it's a really white fake it is a
white pink and i thank you for your time
[Applause]
what a delightful audience and they're
leaving
oh i tell you what never needed a fake
audience more
than i did
wow wait hold on can i
wait oh yeah ah there we go
yes we'll get it one of these days we're
gonna get it
uh beer brand natural
everyone is so badly behaved today beer
brand
natural light launched a line of
alcoholic popsicles that contain eight
percent alcohol by volume
i'll take two said a kid who's sick of
remote learning
oh i know what could take the edge off
okay this is why i don't have any kids
maybe some drug ass kids
according to a new study going
vegetarian can lower
testosterone in men but i'm sure there's
also a downside
and finally actor shamar moore turned
51 this week but he doesn't look a day
over
god damn it's hot
shimar more is a hawk man and that was
the monologue
tarik did you like the monologue i am
contractually obligated to say i did
yeah damn right yeah you better say it
twice
now you guys
there's a reason we've lost our minds
there's another story i want to talk
about
a woman in canada recently broke a
guinness world
record for lowest vocal note ever sung
by a female by singing the note
c1 and it got me thinking how low can i
go
so we thought we'd test it out on the
show okay so
here we go this is my personal lowest
note one time i ordered mcdonald's
delivery even though mcdonald's is
literally the closest
business to my home whoa
that was low all right let me uh let me
try
one time i couldn't find my remote so i
just watched the 700 club for four weeks
straight
time i cried at the end of an episode of
spongebob
one time i accidentally ate the little
piece of paper inside a fortune cookie
one time i ordered a shirt that was too
big and just
wore it as a dress because i was too
lazy to return it
one time my keyboard broke and instead
of fixing it i just didn't write any
words with the letter p
for two months one time i saw
a roach in my shower while i was in
there
and i just let it happen
is that so funny um one time i swiped
right on my ex two weeks after we broke
up
one time i flipped my underwear inside
out instead of doing laundry
one time when i was a kid i peed in the
ocean
and no one saw me but it wasn't an ocean
it was my pants and i wasn't a kid i was
26
and everyone at starbucks saw me
oh we found it that is the absolute
lowest note congratulations derek davis
thank you
i have my own youtube channel now yay be
sure to subscribe for a lot of show
clips and a lot of digital exclusives
and a lot of this
you